I guess David Oh Brown has just entered
the studio hello David how come David
over there one morning how are you let
me guess hey sure worse you've had very
handsome on camera we were watching you
before ah Morning Joe yeah I unload all
the TVs are on what major leads a Dallas
police department in write a book 33
years on the job and it's long enough
all of my adult life my wife and I
decided it was time to go do something
else man and writing a book was about
sharing my experiences with the police
profession in the community I grew up in
so did you find that like as time has
gone on and in the in a place that we're
all living in now that did the job
become more difficult in the sense that
with the way the way police are
perceived and the amount of obviously
the amount of violence that that you had
to deal with in Dallas yes this Ferguson
Missouri
obviously the jobs become more difficult
much more of a fishbowl even more hyper
criticized than normal but while at the
same time the rewards of serving people
makes it still more enjoyable to do the
job and it's one of the few jobs where
you can actually see the results where
you make a street safer or you make a
you know like a domestic violence
incident you make a family safer you
actually get a lot benefits from doing
the job and it's worth the criticism can
you talk a little bit about what
happened in I think there's 2016 when we
got the snipers opened fire on the cops
and Alice we always all really was only
one guy okay so it wasn't one we thought
was more than one initially and but it
would end up being one guy okay and
whatever his motives for doing that and
how did you guys find him we believe he
was a retired Army veteran
we believe he suffered from PTSD and he
attached himself to the black lives
matter movement in a perverted way and
wanted to kill white officers according
to what he said to our negotiators we
can go she ate with him for over three
hours well we had to make a tough
decision to take him out so again he had
killed five officers ambush-style
just walked up on him from behind and
shot him and killed him and officers got
into a running gun battle with him and
chased him into a long hallway on a
second floor of a building there in
downtown Dallas and I was unwilling to
sending more officers down to have
another gun exchange with him he
very accurate very well trained in what
he was doing I didn't want to lose
another officer I have one seriously
injured or killed
and so I weaponized a bomb robot with c4
about a pound of c-4 and and send it
down a long hallway and detonated and
killed him had that been discussed
before was that something you just like
here let's take a shot at this never
been done in American policing Wow ever
and the commander on the ground and I
were discussing how to end it because
this guy was threatening to kill more
officers and it was imminent in our
minds that he was going to actually
carry out that since he's already killed
five and they sent me several options I
told them I don't like any of those be
creative and that was a creative option
and I knew that it was something that
could cost me my job but while at the
same time you know if you think about
the options of sending officers down
that long hallway and getting killed or
using a bomb robot weaponized it was the
right thing to do not do it again so the
robot is one of those robots that are
used to get bombs out right yeah you
would you put c4 on it yes and it
becomes a bomb it's about three feet in
height and it has a extension to
extension arms you can just wrap duct
tape around c4 with the arms with a det
cord and it goes down the long hallway
you got a remote that cord and you got
actual attached det cord as a backup and
press the button we rented it up
negotiations because he was just yelling
and screaming about killing us and so he
couldn't period going down the hallway
until they got too close and then we
pressed it and he looked around the
corner heard a little bit he had his
finger on the trigger and actually a
round went off uh-huh as the explosion
happens and we think we're thinking he's
still alive and we still had to go down
and check to make sure but you know it
was obviously very very very successful
at taking him out but he had mental
problems and was not going to stop he
wasn't going to we tried three and a
half hours here a long time to stand
there and hold a rifle at the end of a
hallway waiting for any moment after
working a 12 hour a day by the way so
this at night people don't remember it
like yeah 10 11 12 o'clock at night just
this is all happening so our folks are
exhausted every cop in the Reid
comes to downtown to help us with this
and so there's no relief factor and so
we have to make a tough decision to end
it and not again like I said before I'd
do it again given the same circumstances
and how long does it take to really
realize what's happening because another
thing people might not remember is it's
a giant protest going on and this guy is
one of a sea of protesters and doubts
and you don't know if there's a movement
like you said it's a guy who had
perverted the black lives matter message
but you don't know if he's got a bunch
of guys with him you don't know if this
is a sect of that group you don't right
into for the longest time you're exactly
right we thought it was multiple
shooters because many of the shots were
at ground level street level but then he
ran upstairs and shot another officer
from the second floor and depending on
when you're arriving and what you're
seeing your vantage point you may think
there's a guy shooting from up there
right and we know that the guy shooting
from down here so for a long time we
thought there were multiple shooters we
have to do in a very exhaustive search
of our downtown and to just throw more
into the mix of already bad situation
there were open carry these folks that
carry rifles in the protest marching
with ar-15s rattle yes Texas yeah so
there's about 20 folks with rifles
marching in the protest I remember that
as the protesters happening and we find
out that this has happened a face pops
up on the news because this guy is
walking around where it's happening with
a gun strapped to him and we're like
we're looking for this guy
and then you find out he's just a dude
who decided to bring his gun he had
nothing to do with it right nothing to
hit but he was wearing fatigues a
bulletproof vest a gas mask all these 20
folks was just kind of you know
protesting their right to carries you
know firearms yeah and and then when the
shooting starts they run and and the
fact that our cops had enough discipline
not to shoot them was extraordinary yeah
after you know watching your fellow
officers being shot and assassinated in
the street you see people running with
ar-15 but you have discipline to to not
take them out and to really zero in on
the one person that was actually doing
all the damage and what do you think is
like the main problems you hear all
these stories there's cops have shot
unarmed black
what is the main problem between the
black community and the police like
who's at fault and like what what if
both sides doing that's contributing to
it let me set the context before I
answer your question so we just recently
had a cop in New York ambushed sitting
in the car really actually - yes this
past week and then two days before that
we had a 10 Antonio cops shot and killed
ambush-style and so there's two sides to
this grief that is praying of losing
people on the officer side and the
citizen side a particularly unarmed
black man where that's the narrative
that's getting put out there that that's
happening but there are many noble brave
courageous officers that give their
lives to protect all of us as well five
on that one day in Dallas who gave their
lives for people who were protesting
them they acted as human shields for
people who were protesting and they ran
toward gunfire for people who were
protesting them and so that's the
context of this conversation about
what's wrong I think what's wrong is
that there's not an appreciation for the
sacrifice officers make and this
difficult conversation we have about
race right it's two sides it's a
two-sided coin and it's very difficult
on both sides do you think that cops
should do a better job of when there is
a shooting that shouldn't happen when a
cop shoots somebody that they shouldn't
have do you think police should do a
better job of acting less as a
fraternity not in a bad way just meaning
Brotherhood and more of a look this cop
did wrong they don't represent us
because there are so many good cops that
it gets clouded when when cops act
improperly I did this as chief I was
chief of the longest serving chief in
Dallas since the 1940s in the modern era
of Dallas I fired more cops who just
weren't suited for the job there are
some cops that just not suited to handle
stress right the difficult decisions you
got to make it a split seconds not
suited to do it and they make the wrong
decisions and unfortunately they paint
the whole profession with a broad brush
yes which is unfair now I know this is
ready you can't see that I'm black right
so I'm black I've been black a long time
all my life so what I hate about what
happens with black people particularly
black men we get stereotyped welcome to
still
or security files you can think going
shopping right right but I also hate
about being a cop 33 years I get
stereotyped right arrow typed but by the
cops who are not soon to have the job
that the one or two percent right so
it's the same stereotype exactly both
right those are unfair both are wrong I
think we ought to hold up the
ninety-eight percent of the top that do
the job the right way and we give their
lives for you and we also need to call
out the ones that are not suited for the
job right you and you achieve when
you're the police chief did you have any
incidents where you're going around and
somebody kind of profiled you or
stereotypes you wrong and you're like
you guys have no idea who you're talking
without knowing that yeah without know
you're in please chief well you know let
me add to this I grew up in the inner
city so I mean I grew up in the hood so
I'm not like middle-class or anything
I've never forgot where I come from so
yes Alex you grew up in Dallas in inner
city so yes a lot of times I've been
stereotyped that way SS chief before I
was chief I mean it is something that
you get used to but it is not an excuse
to be against the law enforcement
community that that is not actually it's
a calling for you to put some skin in
the game and maybe become part of the
law-enforcement community change what I
decide is what I did either he's going
to commit I'm interested kid I want to
be a police officer because of the crack
cocaine epidemic back in the 80s so I
put an application in and my first beat
was my old neighborhood Wow that is what
it takes but that's a difficult thing
right if you show up in your old
neighborhood as a cop especially if it's
if it's inter see if it's the hood like
they don't like cops especially if one
of their people is now a compliment they
got one on the inside now so that's are
like hey why don't we um if some of that
is some of that you can all you give a
brother a break yeah but it's also
something where there's a expectation
that you'll be treated fairly not
somebody from the community so why would
be an advocate for more people from the
community being a part of local
government policing and other parts of
local government to create the
significant change you want to see
protest alone won't cause that it's when
you put in in the game is when you call
significant change and what is deficit
in government do you think
people are having an honest racial
discussion today no I think it's called
for though what do you think it's not
honest about it's not intimate enough I
tell the story about when I was a bust
and dese are doing these desegregation
doing integration in this country and it
was an awful experience so I got busted
all white school and until another 11
year old kid I was in sixth grade eleven
year old kid
white kid invited me home for dinner
nothing changed he invites me home and
dinner we become personal friends it was
a face-to-face authentic relationship
that is what's missing in our
discussions about race we make it too
broad mm-hmm it's not it's not David and
my friend's name who was loving we're
still friends today Mike and David it's
the black guy and the white guy it's got
to be more of an intimate relationship
in order to overcome the wounds of race
in this country do you think two people
are also afraid that every time
specially a racial discussion if you say
something that you know the other side
or the other black guy says about like a
vice versa objects to your pegged is a
racist to you thank you some like we
don't give each other any type of leeway
in the discussion or having to know and
again it's again it's about the intimacy
relationship I don't know your name I
don't know anything about you or your
family so it's easy to make those broad
strokes about your motivations when you
say something out of the way but it's
harder if I know you I know your family
you know me you know my family there's
much more of a benefit of the doubt and
a much more I think a more deeper
conversation about race when we are
willing to get to know each other mm-hmm
and somebody that somebody wants to talk
to you a will in New York I'm sure we
have some call to help your headphones
rub hello will you're on the phone with
us in and David a brown Hey are you
doing guys Jimmy family what's up my man
I just you know I don't know man I hear
what you're saying but it's it's I hear
it's so lopsided like I you what you're
saying you know that or they're great
offices 98% or whatever it is every
officers sacrificing give so much to
protect us but I mean it's lopsided man
you know like you had those cheeks
your initial answer to Jimmy's question
is to mention the awful ambush that
happened the two ambushes that happen
with the officers but it's so lopsided
brother it's so lopsided and I never
hear from from from from you know from
the police community I never from I
never hear you guys just come out and
say yeah it's wrong you know it's
obviously or or yes there is a problem
it's always first let me point out that
I mean it's just hard it's hard brother
like I do you know I grew up here in New
York and it's so lopsided and you guys
never never want to admit or acknowledge
that there might really be a problem
it's always you know you always got to
defend yourselves first and then turn
around and say yeah maybe there's a
problem look you know I mean like yeah I
understand what you're saying let me let
me save it let me say this if you don't
mind I'll be the first to say there are
officers are not suited to carry the gun
and badge there are and I don't know if
that satisfies you but there are
officers and officers know this other
officers know it's a guy I don't want to
ride with because he always gets me in
trouble how it always had me and I was
something he did I think the issue is
that that that sentiment is never a
public sentiment but you don't you don't
hear that because officers want to
defend the good officers which I get and
they want to defend the 98 percent but
in defending the 98 percent the 2
percent doesn't get called out enough to
make the people who feel like they're
victims
satisfied right so I don't disagree with
you but again we depend on that 98
percent to protect all of us yeah I
cannot discourage them by painting with
a broad brush and that now I'm not
willing to run to our bullets when
you're running away from bullets right
you think that we're getting a lot of
money for this right no we're not 60
grand 80 grand to risk your life so we
got to keep we got to balance the
conversation and not just make that 2
percent all about the 2% to done deserve
to have a job I'd be willing to say it a
hundred times that they don't deserve to
have a job but at the same time I've got
to encourage my
8% to continue to run toward bullets to
risk their lives for us so again it's
got to be a balanced conversation I
don't disagree with you though sir you
make a great point all right thank you
very much for the call thanks a lot what
do you guys think or what did you think
at the time of the movements like black
lives matter who were that the whole
point of the movement is to be critical
of the way of black people are treated
by police like that I mean they're doing
something they're doing it for the most
part I in my opinion in the right way in
the sense that protest I think are good
you throw sure protests make you aware
of a problem yes they don't create
significant change since it started
what's changed right exactly
what what and it we got a history of
this so if we if I found the father's
all they did was throw tea in the Boston
Harbor and didn't fight and write a
constitution and create a government and
then serving government we still be
speaking the King's English you saying
that protesting without knowing the next
step without without action what's an
action day again I quit school at the
inner-city kid my senior in college
because of the crack cocaine epidemic
and put in an application and became a
Dallas cop to be part of the solution
you have to put some skin in the game
it's the history of this country this is
what the World War two generation did
they put skin and again they risk their
lives to protect democracy from tyranny
you think about the civil rights
movement that generation of folks they
not only put skin again they risk their
lives but then people like John Lewis
got elected to government and been
serving for more than 30 or 40 years it
protests alone is required in our
democracy I think it's something that is
a tradition and then the next steps are
also as much an obligation to create
significant change and you write down
your book is called called to rise is
the book that Chief David Brown is
promoting just so people know you have a
book out which covers all this stuff in
your life yeah and I'm only being
devil's advocate here I'm not but uh but
what about the people who don't who
think that action is that next step I
mean you talk about the Boston Tea Party
the next step was was violence it wasn't
joining the British government it was a
violent upheaval throughout the
government and I don't think that we
want to
encourage people to think that that
let's keep it in context yeah it's
because there wasn't a democratic
process to have what they saw as their
rights not being heard we have a
democracy now because of that it and the
democracy is more local so the police
chief all the police officers are hired
by people who are voted into office so
think about local elections what's the
participation rate Dallas just had a
local election it's not dissimilar from
New York's about 6% is a high
participation rate in a local election
and this makes the difference on how the
police treat you you can hire and fire
the police chief and all the officers if
you don't like it but you can't expect
any significant change of 94% of the
people stay home when it's time to make
that change at the voting booth so
you're saying the fact that we've set up
a system where people actually have
access to be a part of the political
system and to be members of of the
political system is the difference it's
why the civil rights movement focused on
the Voting Rights Act right because they
knew that's where the change would
actually come with the right to vote but
then when the local election rolls
around its single-digit participation
percentage-wise right you're not going
to see any significant change until you
invert that participation rate somebody
has a nice compliment for you as well um
let's see here
I'll take compliments yeah Robin in
Tennessee hey what's going on so there's
everybody going hello hey Oh doing
weather one well I was calling because
I'm listening on top right now I
listened to show day I called Sam show
couple times prior to here you know
Bihar in the morning but my daddy's a
police officer as well I'm a black man
so it's spin parity been departed for 20
years and I've always been kind of like
a populist here sighs I just that's
always been like being when I try to
until the classic phone it is your phone
okay I can you move the location for a
second to you we're trying to hear you
but it's the crackling is really bad
okay we move sorry I'm right near radio
can hear me out
um it justice to you and I have a call
right
I have a staticky faux if you hang up on
it I'll take your calls you call right
back we just it's burn the orders really
bad welders are all right thanks Ron is
it is it difficult to go back to the job
after an incident as traumatic as the
shooting in Dallas
it is very difficult because we had to
plan five funerals five grieving widows
and their kids look I need you here man
these are these are and it's it's been a
year but the wound is open and it's not
healed it will forever change the Dallas
Police Department is that what motivated
you to retire no actually it was it was
time to retire I was trying to turn it
over to someone else I had done all I
came to do I achieved the lowest crime
rate of any chief in Dallas history had
a you know 70 year low murder rate in
the history since the 1930s and it was
just time to move on to the next phases
those jobs are limited I believe that
you know public service should have his
limitations or how long you stay you
should turn over somebody else with
fresh new ideas and for 33 years is a
long time well it's a long time to serve
well were you right before you were
chief which one - what's the rank right
before chief I was second-in-command the
first assistant chief for six years
prior to being chief I had been a patrol
cop I kind of street cop I wore uniform
every day you know I'm old school I was
in Swat for a very long time so I got
you know at the height of the drug wars
and the mass incarceration I was right
in the middle of it as a young cop and
on in fact in terms of in terms of
coming up with new and fresh ideas once
that c4 robot gets introduced you're
probably thinking that's yeah that's my
that's my closer you know you want to go
out on top yes at the time Chiefs are
run out tarred and feathered now so it
is not an appreciated job you make tough
decisions you make the cops mad at you
sometimes and sometimes you make the
community mad at you you can't please
everybody you shouldn't be trying to it
should have its limitations just so that
you know you know it can be turned over
to someone else that can kind of kind of
ease some of some of the things that
you've had to make as far as tough
decisions are concerned Ryan is back on
the phone Rhonda from Tennessee all
right guys here we go yeah Maya
good deal good deal good deal now I will
just call you there you know everybody
props really but you know the thing
about it is I'm a Tennessee and I called
Sam show couple times we had
when the incidence has happened down in
Texas you know my dad is a police
officer and I'm a son so it's like one
of those things where I've always been
caught one of those things he's been a
detective for more than 20 years now I'm
actually going out for the fire
department but you know just getting
ready burger pops and say I appreciate
what you did and what you done thank you
and you know if you go what you're doing
I miss I mean especially like I said
with Ray's being such a big issue in
this country
it's got to be trying for yourself now
you going to a lot in addition I would
be at the show on Saturday to Jim so
national help oh yeah man ok about 40
minutes away
all right thanks fine I'll see you
national I appreciate it what's it be
there all right but you uh you worry
I think big on transparency yes when you
were so when you were the chief which is
not something that a lot of cops
historically have been in sales right
but that I think that it's kind of
brilliant to be transparent about it
because that is where a lack of trust
bills isn't going right here's what I
thought about police information
including identities of cops the police
involved shootings all the details I
thought it was the people's information
we were current takers that it was never
our information to keep right that if we
were truly public servants we were
supposed to serve the public including
all the information that belongs to the
public and I would be the first to admit
my mistakes if a cop did something that
was outside the rules all the laws I
always had a rule be the first to admit
well nothing you think you might have
done wrong but yeah as a chief what's a
mistake but I think one of the things
that you know I have a lot of obviously
tough decisions to make
I didn't do a good job with the media I
should have taken them out to more
coffees and lunches and stuff to get
along with them more but I didn't about
them are very very dismissive with media
I can saw I just started to get the job
the right way that would be enough
shirts but it's not I was very naive in
an area and I wasn't very good at
politics I need to make the tough
decisions and let the politicians spin
it in whatever direction and getting
involved in that so if I had to do it
all over again I'd probably do a better
job at smoothing with the media and
politics the job would speak for itself
but you've got to talk to them a little
bit right and the media is your
vessel communication to the people
you're representing right that's right
but they spin everything do you think
they do it's crazy how they're allowed
to do that right and we also want to I
wanted to ask you - what did you think
of the shooting that was on Facebook
that was a really a polarizing one with
the army thoroughly panicked yelling up
not suited for the job
should there be I don't know about jail
for an officer but it's like it's hard
to say like when you just shoot a guy in
cold blood that there shouldn't be any
kind of a like if you're recklessly
driving you can go to jail for it right
so what do you think the penalty for a
guy like that should be where he clearly
made a terrible mistake here's where I
think's happening to jurors and we don't
want it to change our jury system of
criminal justice we don't want to
vigilante this thing core so here's what
I think jurors are doing they're making
a calculation on this reasonable doubt
standard so to get a conviction got to
be beyond a reasonable doubt and where
that doubt comes in is that when this
cop risk his life for us every day right
and so he didn't come to work intending
on killing somebody and they want to
give a cop the benefit of the doubt and
they transfer that sentiment to the
legal process of beyond a reasonable
doubt did they kill someone and they
shouldn't but I don't know that's human
nature kind of playing on the door yeah
you're inserting emotion into something
that should be by-the-book like I
understand you get why and you feel
sympathy for this person but that's not
it's not a place for sympathy that's why
the legal aid so you get some hung
juries when we all want convictions in
some of these cases but that ends up
being worse I think bigger picture
because then the people who are not
jurors who didn't sit through the trial
who didn't feel the sympathy that the
jurors felt are just seeing ingested
perceived injustice as another cop that
got away with it right but you know of
course you know there is a case the
Walter Scott case in Psych honor where
the officer took a plea plea agreement
and got 20 years force you norm black
man solders but that was that was so
agreed just as always from the back yeah
I'm on my way
ulaana no one can spin that as to
anything other than what it was yeah
right but part of it is I mean I think
penalties have to be severe when stuff
like that happens so that because you
know
you know I you feel sympathetic and you
understand why it happens because the
job of an officer has got to be the most
high-pressure job in the world like you
said you are defending people you're
putting your life on the line for other
people but part of that I think pressure
that you feel has to be if I screw up
I'm going to feel the same consequences
that anybody else would feel if not
worse and it's just part of the gig
right and so this we're talking about
jurors now the DA's bring the case to
the grand jurors you get an indictment
now you're at trial we're talking to
jurors so we're talking to everyday
people in the community about this idea
of the legal standard of beyond a
reasonable doubt
don't transpose that or just oppose that
on to well let's give them the benefit
of that because he's a cop and he saves
us every day right so forth everything
Gerry and Chicago wants to talk to -
David hello Jerry hey what's going on
guys are you hi sir is you know on call
and I'm sorry you ready oh no I'm sorry
let me turn this out awesome thank you
so I wanted to give a call and I kind of
had a question but as I was thinking
about it a little bit more what less
from a question into a comment you noted
if you choose to respond that would be
great I think you probably will I grew
up in the inner city of Chicago or group
Englewood I've worked in the corporate
world downtown in Chicago also a 10 year
military vet and you know and I heard
you make the comment about taking
responsibility and kind of joining the
force you know I think that's a
difficult thing to say you know because
when I was in grade school I'll try to
make yourself more than grade school
pretty much every kid that you asked
what they wanted to be they just said
they want to be a doctor a fireman or a
police officer and I think growing up in
the city of Chicago one other thing that
does is it taints
when you're in an environment where the
police officers just are nice to you and
I think when when you go up in that type
of environment and then you see that
these people aren't responding to you
the way that someone should and I think
it makes it even worse when those people
look like you do you know there's been
examples where I was going to play
basketball before my friends police
pulled us over because we lived in a
high crime area police pulled us over
they searched us we're out there for ten
minutes and so I had a look on my face
of disgust and appreciation obviously
because we aren't doing anything with
high school kids going to play
basketball right and so the cop asked me
he's like well what's wrong with you and
all that what'd you put us over for no
reason and you kind of just wasting our
time right now I don't feel like it's
fair right and he's our you know what's
fair I'll slap the [ __ ] out of you and
write on the ticket because I [ __ ]
felt like and they take you to jail
right you know at what point does I do I
feel like oh you know what I should do I
should join the military I mean I should
join the police force so I can help
change this and actuality what it does
is it make me feel be humanized yeah
this is a conversation this is a
conversation I had with my old man my
dad when I came home from college my
senior and said I'm going to be a police
office he said you're making a mistake
he tried to talk me out of it my old man
said police officers disrespect the
community you don't want to be a part of
that and my response and my rebuttal to
my dad I was that's why I need to be a
police officer because I want to change
that because I want to change that and
moment was what he was disappointed with
me and that decision all the way until I
was promoted to lieutenant and then if
my my lieutenant promotion ceremony he
came out and said son you made the right
decision
I'm proud of you you know I a they make
me cry biology still acting up quite a
bit yeah it was it was a similar moment
for me because I had the same difficulty
that you had and making that decision
even when I went to police headquarters
to fill out the application the
secretary looked at me because I was an
inner-city kid I think I had a t-shirt
and blue jeans on because she looked at
me and said they're not going to hire
you meaning we're not going to hire any
city kid and I was insisting I demanded
that they treat me the same way they
would treat anybody else I got hired and
I became police chief in her and at her
retirement ceremony I handed her her
plaque with a smirk on my face that
night I'm the police chief that you said
that you said we're not going to hire
did she remember you no she didn't
remember I did it but tell her that you
told me that I didn't I didn't I didn't
I wanted Superman I wanted to flaunt it
but I just had a smirk and just talked
to myself you know you said I could
be a police officer and now I'm the
police you to hand you your retirement
data also thank you for the call Jerry I
wanted to talk a little bit too about
what happened with your son because you
talked about your dad a little bit and I
think that was in 2010 2010 a month on
the job after being appointed police
chief my son who at the time was 27
years old and was undiagnosed adult
onset for bipolar which is very common
apparently in this country and
self-medicating with street drugs
remaining worse it makes it much worse
they think it makes it better people who
are suffering from an illness thinks it
makes it better instead of taking the
prescribed drugs but my son was
undiagnosed the family meeting the rest
of the family was unaware that he was
experiencing he lived on his own not not
in the house anymore did you have a good
relationship and had the relationship he
was not a violent person at all this
bipolar mental mental illness is
devastating to my family until I'm sure
other families did you in hindsight do
you see like oh that's and that was no
so you didn't you didn't there were no
manic episodes growing up no nothing no
no it all set yeah it is the Oh John
John Haley sitting there dormant and
then it just hit him as an adult man
about 20 27 years old okay which makes
it even more difficult to diagnose
because he's sitting there going I'm 27
I'm not I'm grown yeah and you can't
make them do nothing even if you are
aware you know it's ever difficult in
this in this country not I share that
because there are other people
experiencing that with their loved ones
what happened to how did you how did you
notice something was wrong or how did it
get out of control when he had what was
we thought was a electic seizure but
that is one of the triggers for this is
composing and you know talking about
rapidly and and and he didn't know we
didn't know took him to the hospital it
calmed down and never happened again for
a couple years and then this incident
happens where he gets a gun we the only
gun I had in the house was a gun I
carried so he got a gun from someone I
don't know who and killed an innocent
bystander and killed a suburban cop and
then was subsequently killed Wow and I'm
in church get to get the call from the
detectives in the suburban city that
this happened and my life will never be
the same
yep yeah the gun issue too and it's
either we all feel both ways about it
like and you're in a pretty open carry
rare area so people say that that cuts
down on crime there's other people that
say it's insanity as someone who lives
there and who's a cop there what do you
think I recounted that I had the lowest
murder rate since the 1930s in Dallas
and it's a very liberal gun state almost
everyone has a gun in Texas and
particularly in the urban centers but
then you go to cities like Chicago a
very restrictive gun state and look at
what happened what's happened in Chicago
and in California very restrictive and
San Bernardino happens mm-hmm go to
Florida and the shooting at the club
there happens so all the carry your own
carrots
well I don't know I didn't say that I
would go that far I think here's what we
ought to do we ought to at least find a
way to put some gum restrictions on
things we all agree on the mentally ill
shouldn't be able to get a gun yes yeah
we all agree on that but that is not the
law across this country right now people
it is you peel back the layers of what's
happened with these multiple shootings
all mental health issues yeah forget
about in Dallas this guy was mentally
ill Jerry TSD suffers that gets released
from the military with that diagnosis
but is able to get a gun
Sandy Hook this person is suffering from
mental illness and that's our diagnosed
diagnosed is still able to get a gun - I
am yes so this is all of what we agree
on I know the difficulty with you know
capacity magazines and assault rifles
I'm not talking that I'm talking about
the tenor this common-sense approach to
restricting people who are suffering
from mental health problems diagnosed -
should be restricted from having access
to a gun okay now being the chief of the
Dallas Police Department you have it now
we talk a lot about conspiracy on this
show so would be negligent to not ask
you because of Dallas of course is where
Kennedy was shot and there's nothing
that the doubt please our got a terrible
rap because of that they shouldn't have
front there's nothing that the Dallas
Police Department knows that they
haven't told everybody know aside from
aliens there's not that's what I mean
isn't it it's silly the way people think
that this is information don't in the
way of a good conspiracy
people live that deal for conspiracy so
you know have edit but having as it can
as a police chief it would it take too
much effort for all those officers to
cover up something like that like is it
a possibility for a bunch of officers
and the chief to cover up this whole
thing with Oswald no and it's not a
possibility what I did is chief because
we came up on the 50th anniversary of
the Kennedy assassination during my
tenure as chief I went back and got the
witnesses there there was someone in
Texas theater and then there was someone
in the shoe store across the street and
there 80 years old now and they had
never been acknowledged for helping
capture Oswald and I brought them in and
did a big ceremony and we talked about
it to the media we talked about what
they saw what they did and and how they
help the police wrestle him to the
ground in the Texas theater and gave him
I wore got I got pictures in my office
of this and so Dallas had buried all of
the history of the Kennedy assassination
and at the fiftieth anniversary I began
to start recognizing the people who were
associated with it including some of the
officers have you been in the sniper's
nest I know that they have it uh
they have a half a glass off did you
actually have the object class yep Wow
yeah yeah yeah it's not a difficult
sniper shot actually it's not right not
at all
no he's very easy so you're a single and
I didn't plan discussions I was former
SWAT so I kind of know this issue of
what's difficult and what's not and in
the fall of a year no tree foliage you
know elevated position very slow-moving
car is very easy sniper shot and
somebody wanted to add a garden ask
about the transparency we were talking
about and being the chief did you have
officers and especially some of your
viewpoints on on some officers not being
equipped to have a badge did you have I
don't know if the words hostility but
where there are no there is hostility in
the police union bosses man they didn't
like it want to fire me from that one
every day one to fire me work to fire me
every day but they're my best friends
now of course after July 7th I'm
heralded as this great leader but every
day what the hell then yes you a it took
I mean literally your entire career yes
because you were tied
what seven months ago say about two
months after July yeah in October of
2016 our retired so you had you at two
months I'm having them off your back for
you I actually too much no no then hold
it officers accountable you put your you
put your job on the line now I'm willing
to I thought that would have if they
were able to be successful they'd fire
me
that would have been a good firing
everything worth holding officers
accountable in my opinion yeah that'd be
great to send your resignation in with a
robot we have to wrap their tell you
said I guess you have other press it's
David Ober I was great such a
fascinating interview uh Chief David
Brown on Twitter and I'm so honest and
you're so open about everything the good
demand and it's called to rise is the
name of the book and I'm sure it will do
very very well I'm going to read I wish
we had in advance I would have read it
just to be better property brother and I
mean it was like for those guys I
remember I was I was doing my
broadcasting so doing nights at the time
and I was broadcasting live as as the
Dallas thing was happening just
everybody talking about it and
everything and it really was to to of to
have not only lived through that but led
the the
eventual positive result of it I think
is it's an amazing thing like you were
to me I'm pretty grated thank you